à ces mobilisations contre le pass annie
terre avec un autre éditorialiste et
sociologue michel fize
michel fiset bonjour ont toujours un
plaisir de vous recevoir sur ce plateau
alors la troisième dose 1,10 dit dose de
rappel va être indispensable pour garder
elles sont pas sanitaire valide à partir
du 15 janvier est-ce que c'est audible
pour les français en tout cas pas pour
ce qu'on vient d'entendre je crois que
les les français sont dans une grande
lassitude chacun de nous aujourd'hui un
peu le sentiment qu'on est dans dans une
farce
interminables queues que rien n'avance
que quand on croit avancé d'un côté
finalement on recule de l'autre alors
j'ai envie de dire par rapport aux mots
liberté qui vient d'être employé un
instant que quelque part ce variant
omikron est un variant profit dambron
financieele profits dans ciel pour
imposer de nouvelles restrictions aux
libertés a on le voit aux pays bas avec
la fermeture des commerces d'un
essentiel bars et restaurants entre 17
heures le soir et cinq heures du matin
donc on a l'impression effectivement
d'une peur panique qui à nouveau s'est
emparée des états du monde entier je
pense que nos sociétés aujourd'hui elle
souffre d'être saoul empire de l'émotion
là on est dans l'émotionnel en
permanence il faut créer du ce de la
sensation et les politiques qui
devraient avoir un peu de recul n'en
n'ont pas eux-mêmes voilà donc il tombe
effectivement dans quelque chose qui
ressemble des des scénarios
hollywoodiens on le voit avec les
fermetures des frontières
aujourd'hui pour tout ceux qui
reviennent d'afrique d'afrique australe
va je pense que on est dans la démesure
réactive voilà ça c'est extrêmement
préoccupant alors vous en parlions du
couvre-feu nocturne aux pays bas il ya
d'autres pays européens qui optaient
pour le confinement et si ça devait
arriver en france est ce que les
français seraient prêts à l'accepter je
pense que le le confinement serait
socialement politiquement et
psychologiquement extrêmement dangereux
d'abord socialement parce que évidemment
une nouvelle fois les liens sociaux les
liens entre les individus serait
brutalement des faits psychologiquement
parce qu'on a vu évidemment toutes les
conséquences sanitaires au plan
psychologique voire psychiatrique
et puis politiquement à quelques mois
évidemment d'une échéance présidentielle
ce n'est certainement pas une mesure qui
serait et qui serait populaire moi je
crois qu'elle est tout simplement
impensable je vois pas comment on
pourrait dans un contexte de tension
comme on le voit aujourd'hui comment on
pourrait reléguer né un 7 mesures
autoritaires privative de liberté parce
que quand on privé liberté
ponctuellement bon ça peut passer ah
mais quand la privation devient un état
permanent évidemment on est dans ce
qu'on a appelé en d'autres temps un coup
d'état permanent on a donc je crois
qu'encore une fois cette mesure
n'est n'est pas pensable dans notre pays
c'est vrai qu'il ya cette notion
d'acceptabilité sociale qu'est ce qui
complique finalement cette acception de
nouvelles mesures à ce qu'on ait une
communication qui n'est pas vraiment
clair en france je pense que bon il ya
un problème de communication
il ya un problème d'absence aussi de
concertation on est toujours face à une
situation où un seul décide pour tous
dans l'urgence dans la dans la
précipitation pas dans une démocratie
qui par définition c'est le partage de
tous et le partage des opinions des
idées il est évident que on peut se
sentir légitimement frustrée de ne pas
être associé aux réactions qu'on doit
prendre face à une face à une situation
mais je pense que on est dans des dans
des situations aussi on amplifie on
amplifie les peurs voilà à partir de
données incertaine je crois que tout ce
qu'on dit
à propos du du variant au micro n'est
est absolument sans valeur en fait on ne
sait pas on ne sait pas si ce vaccin est
évidemment plus dangereux plus
contagieux on aimait quelques hypothèses
on prend dix quelques cas un cas un cas
en belgique quelques cas aux pays-bas et
pillon on amplifie et et on provoque un
peu une panique générale chez les uns et
une colère monstre chez chez les autres
voilà donc on est perdant perdant dans
tous les cas voilà et surtout ce qui est
très très grave c'est qu'on voit le
monde se fracturait en deux là pour le
coup on a vraiment le monde des riches
vacciner et le monde des pauvres qui ne
qui ne l'est pas il faut savoir que en
afrique subsaharienne comme on la nomme
un les deux tiers des gens ne sont pas
vaccinés et pour le tiers le tir qui est
vacciné et bien le tiers finalement
concerne seulement 10% de la population
là en amérique latine moins de 40 % des
gens sont vaccinés donc il ya un fossé
supplémentaires il y avait les quarts
des riches et des pauvres du point de
vue financier il ya maintenant ce même
écart du point de vue du la point de vue
de la santé voilà donc ça ce sont
effectivement des bombes à retardement
si on peut pas accepter qu'un monde
s'interroge hors jeu aujourd'hui sur la
troisième dose 1 alors que la plus part
d'humanité n'a pas encore accès à la
première dose ou en toutes petites
quantités alors c'est impossible de ne
pas penser de ne pas parler de ce qui se
passe aux antilles françaises on l'a vu
un mouvement qui est parti de là de la
protestation contre l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants des pompiers
contre le passage était finalement on
voit bien que ça a révélé une véritable
crise sociale mais d'abord bon c'est
vrai que par rapport au vaccin on n'est
pas n'est pas habitué au principe de
l'obligation d'une part bon d'autre part
il faut aussi référé les choses aux
cultures traditionnelles
dans les antilles comme dans d'autres
dans d'autres sociétés il ya quand même
une méfiance je dirais presque
congénitale par rapport au principe même
du médicament on voit bien dans beaucoup
de reportages en ce sens les médecines
naturelles ce sont les plantes sont les
herbes avec lesquels avec lesquels on se
soigne et est souvent pas plus mal
qu'avec des médicaments classiques pas
là donc je pense que on doit entendre la
préoccupation de gens qui se disent
comme en métropole d'ailleurs mais on ne
sait pas dans 10 ou 15 ans s'ils ne
surgiront pas des effets secondaires
très grave par rapport à ces
vaccinations parce que bon aujourd'hui
on nous dit troisième dose mais il n'y
aura pas de quatrième dose parce que de
la troisième dose va être protectrice
j'ai envie de dire presque advitam
eternam
on n'en sait rien donc quelque part
c'est au pire une erreur est au mieux un
mensonge voilà donc je pense qu'il faut
pas il faut pas faire de plans de plan
sur la comète et surtout partager encore
une fois les ressources disponibles en
l'occurrence les ressources
médicamenteuse et permettre à chacun de
pouvoir évidemment se soigner ni cncs on
peut garder un petit peu d'espoir un
petit peu d'optimisme surtout en ces
périodes de fêtes de fin d'année bon
évidemment noël noël approchent on
espère tout ce qu'on pourra
le passé en famille avec avec des amis
bon maintenant il faut voir quelle va
être la solidité des vaccins qui ont été
injectés est ce qu'ils vont nous
protéger du nouveau variant bon on dit
que oui on suppose on suppose que oui
donc bon il faut quand même rester
résolument optimiste comme on dit le
pire n'est jamais certain
merci michel fils d'avoir été avec nous
sur ce plateau en bout merci